hello and welcome to this video playing
runs wide to pray okay so we've got a
bullet rating of 2,000 yeah and the
Blitz rating of two six uh-huh okay okay
I'm going to watch that game very
carefully
yeah okay I report this guy everything's
cool yeah every move takes four seconds
you know you can you can set the clock
you know and it doesn't matter how bad
my movers yeah so a better a good so
let's say him and him now we'll move
move so he's on for five and I will do
whatever let's say what would do I play
Queen d7 or something
one two three move yeah I mean you know
you know what I don't get is with those
guys oh that was a quick move what I
don't get with those people is how do
they get it so high with their rating
people should report them before that is
what I don't get some of somebody like
that should be reported a long time ago
one two three four move whatever what a
waste
I mean at least Andy unleashes to get
the points back yeah and some other
platforms you don't get two points back
okay
I know it takes longer not very very
human efficiency three now I would
probably go on and win the game and then
hit solid cheetah
it would be fun but seems unlikely it's
kind of how pointless is that it is so
utterly pointless you know okay so is he
going c5 there or is it going c5
hmm cannot really move the night or that
well I would like to go night is six he
has the c5 idea which is quite which is
quite a pain
yeah what's not happy about this but and
the the worth of this game is rather
academic
or two of this is the right way to
phrase it it has no one lets a sporting
value because it's just like it makes no
sense to play answer comp so now h4
really odd
mm-hmm okay yeah there's a huge for cam
I cannot take on h4 due to g4 with and
my rook is strapped
I wonder if loop the edge if there is a
tactic tactic on d6 probably yes there's
a tactic on d6 maybe there's something
better I mean the engine will show three
four yeah it's kind of pointless you're
alone on this one I don't know let's do
this
what is the best way to track my book
the CSS some cool way to track marouk
well it's not not a bad way to play
technically
and now Lucas is 7b7 winning the bishop
that's a very nice engine solution you
know very nice I have no way to cover
this I can do this and then what is he
doing now no I know that it takes them
four seconds but I don't know they move
one two we move one two three move all
right come on it's kind of pointless
okay I will report the guy will be
banned we know the deal
shall we analyze this it has it has very
little value and very typically I'm
always to play a [ __ ] opening like
this yeah that's what they like to do
some something crappy yeah that anyway
so I kind of knew that it was intention
from the beginning so it was kind of
pointless Sam it was fairly normal
orders and then yeah when did it fall
apart somehow I don't know yeah this is
already not great yeah my bishop on his
heaviness is really um it's really
suffering bishop c3 is a funny move here
that is one of the top choices and it's
not like yeah it's one of the top
choices you know Knight f3 is also not
super obvious
okay it's a strong move
yeah I suspect that I mean I'm
definitely worse but it gets really ugly
after I played g5 a g5 is a lemon yeah
but again you don't really look all that
hard if you know you're going to lose
anyway
and tea I'm falling apart yeah
okay and then it's not very difficult I
saw this but I just wanted to check if
it takes in five seconds or four yeah
anyway so I'm going to report the guy
will be bent we know the story yeah
thanks for watching the video
okay till the next one I hope against a
human that time bye-bye